[Music]
no one that knows me would ever guess I
get paid to do amateur porn they all
think I'm so proper and ladylike I'm
glad I don't work in porn anymore I'm so
disgusted with myself and I don't ever
want to be reminded of what I have done
I've been in ten amateur lesbian porn
videos to pay for college I don't regret
it at all I worked in the porn industry
and now all I want to do is watch people
have sex I have no idea what to tell my
family when they ask me what my career
is I'm a porn star and there's no way I
can open up about it
I work in porn and I love it because I
can live out my sexual fantasies in a
safe controlled space I'm a porn star I
hate my life and that sex isn't special
to me anymore the industry ruined me and
my life being a porn star is interesting
I have hundreds of guys professing their
love every day I'm pretty sure if they
really knew me they wouldn't say it I am
one of the least important people in the
industry like fetching coffee and stuff
but I still get to say I work in porn
and guys just eat it up without question
I'm a porn star but I don't know how to
tell my new girlfriend I'm afraid I
might scare her away I distance myself
from all my family and friends because
I'm too embarrassed to tell them I'm a
porn star I'm a porn star and can't help
but wonder how many people I pass on the
street have seen me naked working in
foreign gave me a greater sense of self
and a higher standards of men
you
[Music]